Julie is on the line in LA in Louisiana
to start off this hour hi Julie welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave I have a
question about taking out my whole life
insurance policy cash value so I am I
have 2000 and credit card debt I'm
behind on my health payment 1200 I'm
also renting which is 1500 and I owe
various other things like 3,000 to a
friend a thousand to an electrician and
other odds and ends the cash value of
the policy is 2500 and I almost pulled
it out yesterday but my only reluctancy
is that I just have 10 years left to pay
on it and it would be of course 26,000
for $150,000 policy I am single with no
kids I don't plan on having kids while I
think I might have a little regret once
I'm able to pick myself back up that I
would have cashed it out so I really
don't know what to do here I would have
zero regret because it's a piece of crap
okay so you should do your investing in
investments that perform much better
than it does it's basically the payday
lender of the middle-class your 2500
dollars they're going to keep it when
you die and pay the face value and so
you paid extra for a savings account
you'll never get the benefit of its
growing at about one to one point two
percent so it's like a bad savings
account at a bad Bank and so now I have
no regrets at all cashing it out now if
you need life insurance you should get
life insurance in place before you cash
it out and in what you just described to
me I'm a lot more concerned that we find
out what the real problem is underlying
all this stuff than the symptom because
if we clean up all your debts and what
you described to me is still going on
you're going to be right back in a mess
does your out of control kiddo why are
you paying to house payments I I
completely understand
it sounds very messy in it and it is for
the moment I have not been able to work
and that's just why
mental very mental and I know that that
sounds like oh I'll just get on it
inside that I mean what's the nature of
your emotional troubles so I dance in
New Orleans and so you're not I and I
wish I had access to a lawyer to ask
questions but you're not technically an
employee you're a it's a tenant-landlord
situation and I don't understand but
either way you can't be fired but I was
because I'm overweight at 128 pounds 5
foot 4 inches tall and and it's it's
very hard to get up and go but I know
that I I can gain come back I'm sorry
just a second just say so the nature of
your emotional struggles are you were
fired yes in your mind never mind never
mind unjustly fired obviously that's all
right so what do you what do you make a
year when you were working um it it's
fluctuates I can make I I don't know a
year I I don't do my own taxes and I
just I I pay my taxes at the end of the
year whatever I'm told so I don't know
but I know that I could folder 30 lb 33
ok so what do you wanna be doing when
you're 53 um that's a great question and
I don't have the answer to that I know
I'm an entrepreneur at heart okay I
think I think you get a fresh start now
I think the thing you were putting off
because you were comfortable where you
were I think you now got a chance to go
do it okay am I wrong so so if you wait
if you wait tables and deliver pizza so
you get your new business started to eat
you're not you're not incapable of doing
that if you had a plan your problem is
you don't have a plan right now and it's
paralyzed you
okay am I wrong oh well my plan is am I
wrong not and no fine no no I mean it's
okay yeah it's okay if you think I am
telling me I'm um it's not honest
question do you think you everybody I
would like the collateral cash in hand
to be able to start a business and I
currently believe that this is my
fastest route if I could just get over
feeling a lack of confidence a newfound
lack of confidence and that yeah and and
I'm presenting the idea that it might be
something different it might be that
that was the last time you'll ever do
that for a living and you're about to
change and that might be the most
awesome thing that ever happened to you
in your life right now it hurts like
crap I hear that I get you understand
there's nothing like a good dose of
rejection to just kind of kick you in
the gutter doesn't it right yeah I got
you up in there understand hey we have a
program that Christy Wright does called
business boutique equipping women to
make money doing what they love how to
start and run a business I'm gonna send
you copy the book because you need an
income stream and then you're gonna have
to get organized and apply that income
stream to straighten this mess up
because $2,500 doesn't fix your problems
that much I'm sorry it's seventy five
hundred either way it just is a
temporary fix and you need to sell the
house immediately and you need to get
organized and address these issues
head-on and you can't let one guy do you
know one character and define you by
getting fired most of us have been fired
I got fired one time and I still don't
know why I probably deserved it but I
just wish the guy had told me why you
know cuz I'm still bitter I just long
time ago you're gonna be okay you need a
plan though and I think this is a fresh
start I think you need to quit brooding
over your past
let's just go forward that's just an
opinion from an old man on the other
side of the other side of the microphone
hold on
I'll give you a copy of business
boutique and we'll get you moving to the
next step we appreciate your call